If you want to get a politician to
change the subject, ask them
how they're going to deal with the
federal debt, which is growing
to be bigger than all of the US GDP
and has us on a path to fiscal
disaster.
That's what happened when I asked
GOP presidential candidate Vivek
Ramaswamy what he would do
to cut spending.
He said he'd focus instead on
supercharging the economy
so that we can grow our way out
of it.
It's as though we've forgotten
that's an option. And all of those
projections that say we're going to
run out of money, assume
you know fairly enough, I guess, the
current GDP growth rate.
And if you extrapolate that out,
yes, we're going bust economically,
you know, financially and fiscally
speaking. It doesn't have to be that
way.
Our government has been on an
economic bender for this entire
century.
And in 2023, the national
debt held by the public will be
roughly equal to our gross domestic
product, and the debt is projected
to get bigger and bigger over the
coming years.
We already know the Boomer response
to questions about cutting spending,
especially entitlements.
And I won't cut a single bit of
Medicare or Social Security.
Under no circumstances should
Republicans vote to cut a
single penny from Medicare or
Social Security.
So what happens when you bring up
cutting spending to Vivek
Ramaswamy? He starts talking about
unleashing economic growth so guess
what?
We don't really have to tackle the
major drivers of debt and deficits.
We've grown at more than four plus
percent GDP growth for most of our
national history.
If we get back to a three handle,
three point something, actually
most of those fiscal problems are
completely gone.
According to figures from the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget
Office or CBO, since 1970,
annual GDP growth has averaged
2.7%, helped
along by a rapidly growing labor
force thanks to immigration, the
baby boom and women going
to work.
So what happens if Ramaswamy becomes
president and is actually able to
unleash economic growth that
pushes the US economy to average
4% annual GDP growth
for two full terms?
Would most of our fiscal problems
be completely gone?
Not even close.
The CBO already projects that
GDP will grow by 2% per
year through 2033.
For argument's sake, let's assume
that GDP growth runs twice that at
4% a year, a rate
far above what it's been so far
in the 21st century.
In a recent report, the CBO
estimated that for every 1.2
percentage points that GDP exceeds
its projected level for 2033,
the deficit would be $51
billion smaller.
By that measure, if GDP growth
ran 4% instead of 2% over
those eight years, the projected
deficit in 2033
of $1.4 trillion
would be cut almost in half
to about $700 billion.
In other words, we'd be better off,
but the government would still be
running red ink every
year and the federal debt would
just keep growing.
We can't let Ramaswamy or
anyone running for president duck
questions about cutting spending.
These guys want to steer clear of
the third rail of American politics;
Social Security and Medicare
entitlements.
But we have to make them grab
it fully with both hands.
If we don't start seriously cutting
spending and scaling back elder
care entitlements, we're not going
to balance the budget or stop
growing the debt.
And our nation's economy
is headed for disaster.